go and rest my name spirit back
welcome to cry oh yeah
I feel so freaking pumped to play this
game this is like the mod of the frickin
century I don't know I'm just so glad
it's a horror game I know the guy has
been working difficult I mean difficult
no way media he's been working like
crazy on this stuff so I know it's gonna
be awesome
and there's gotta be an epic let's play
I hope you brought our dishes pump - I
am piggy yeah yeah pick a poem
alright let's fire this up intro hmm
intro and I'm gonna I don't even know
what I'm talking about but introduction
I always felt oh
for as long as I can remember
I don't know
like I like it mmm where I'm just used
to it that could be an option to miss
being lonely does things to you
Oh angry oh I'm no Tom's I'm sorry I'm
out Hey
all right so that's the story I guess
we're lonely lonely forever alone
forever a trombone okay hmm
so yeah the game takes place in Sweden
to the Jewish is friggin awesome in
Stockholm I'm not I'm from Gothenburg so
I'm not really super familiar hey kid
shake it again got a little crush on the
other end BAE all right
I'm from Gothamites I don't really super
familiar with the subways and all that
but I'm still pumped about it
[Music]
uh-huh I thought it was like only three
guy oh there is something never mind
or maybe not now I just dig it student
onion can't forget about him sorry I'll
probably make this episode a little
longer since we have all this intro and
that kind of stuff lost our last set
after that ever trail eight plus of
wildly again until I get oh I forgot to
say this models made by the same guy who
made afraid of monsters so that's pretty
awesome
more Reubens perhaps probably not gonna
miss really oh that's not cry of fear
all right enough introduction let's just
do this
[Music]
ah there's the main cannon take stock
homes mr. boo get it everything so song
Lee yeah what it's like star comes
addict or something like that it's then
hey I can try and save stuff for you cuz
I'm Swedish alright this is another day
strolling around stretching around on
the street lovely absolutely Dave Lee oh
snap he's crawling like a Bartlett oh
[ __ ] I believe oh no what happened to
him it's really awesome then sweetie
uh-oh he's like ah it's to tell you oh
my god damn right in his face well
actually in probably his waist but could
have been his face
did we die Oh period definitely we died
oh hell that face oh no are we insane
know that sexy face what's up with a
oh no what the hell are we doing
Oh was that me wake up but I have a wig
I think at least oh that's creepy as
hell
taketake camera all right
what that was an awesome intro alright I
have a camera wow what an improvement
from afraid of monsters this looks
awesome
can I take photos hey I can take powder
I gotta take photos of gear I'm gonna
take foot all this coke coke and light
my favorite my CDs obviously share poach
for me alright I do it for your people
damn you look good now you don't hate
mom okay this one better say I love you
nothing really Oh doors awesome alright
another one hey not that duh this one
better say I love you buddy
why doesn't it say oh alright didn't say
I love you but it didn't say something
alright let's go down here lovely
clickety clack I just open doors like a
boss but it's [ __ ] what the hell is that
what is that what is all of this huh
okay stop not buddy
alright hey another day did I see
something else
no oh oh it's me hey don't punch the
mirror what the hell is going on here
alright well I want to take photos of
all of them oh that's disturbing
that is disturbing indeed alright
hello are you happy Sallah
everybody is happy I gotta walk forever
for this no no she does everywhere oh my
god oh oh that was an intro that was
definitely an intro brothers
all right I think I go got an idea what
I'm about to expect in this custom dad
that's not even a custom say it's a mod
our half-life I don't even know anymore
I don't even know it's a corridor I hate
corridors god damn it did I get here
teleportation and nor masturbation Oh No
[Music]
I'm alright it's getting dark and I
don't even have a phone credit alright
damn it dad oh stop stop stop stop stop
all right we are last in the city this
looks awesome
I can't believe it this is a half half
my mother and I can change all right
hold it
god damn this is too awesome send one
there from here on you can drop equip
and combine items
what combining can I combine this paper
I know
Oh bollocks that you can hold shift blue
bar come back here your criminal scum
follow the period that's what my mama
always said find a code to unlock you
[ __ ] it
alright I find the code like a bow find
a code alright cool cool actually game
that's enjoyable to play I'm kidding
alright alright so I guess the padlocks
are like chop chop chop
whoa outside
why was that I want to [ __ ] with me
it's [ __ ] my knife you [ __ ] with this
bring a [ __ ] hello
nobody phone can we use a soft light how
do I switch it on I need to figure out
how to use the phone sooner or later
lovely oh I remember these hey bite I
don't need this now but I want can you
ride bicycles in a horror game that will
be like my best day ever
alright so this isn't dead end let's
keep going I suppose stab all right
let's go here I suppose god damn it this
is creepy all right nothing unusual here
okay maybe how's this coca-cola alright
sorry focus B maybe it's said now I used
it man really Wow this gives me what you
said all right lovely nice run here
Oh note Rhys dose and what rows are
achieved reserved eared
alright fair enough last plots last
flaps an a I put into a hat all right
what did I find here
Julie Julie Houston you'll Jill yours
the name I am [ __ ] [ __ ] I'm sorry
god damn your slaw too much hamburgers
lately I should perish what is this no
hiya pumpkin I'll tell you doing here
pumpkin talk to me pumpkin talk to the
knife or the let me go in here oh we can
awesome a bar really
alright find a code for the padlock I'm
still looking for that alright maybe in
the computer enter username do a deep
tie and the password France alright so I
try to learn controls and stuff like
that and I figured out till nine 17:26
David I guess that's the code we needed
so I'm gonna write that down cuz I have
a really bad memory
alright fourteen stuff like that lovely
Oh what the hell is that grandpa hey
what are you doing that's supposed to
wander the street naked or drunk for
that matter we got about did he come
with that car alright so let's go back
to the padlock whatever the [ __ ] that
was thing was here
hey oh and I figured out how to use the
phone look at this my mom is like where
are you
what does that say no mom I'm playing
horror games here Jesus Christ you can't
just what I don't care okay let's just
go back find a padlock it's over here
and see what's hand
17:36 I think god damn my memory
seriously god damn I [ __ ] memory
but door won't budge I heard that far
many times all right I'm out of breath
it's in here I think at least y'all know
I saw ha getting bad all right
help me in ketchup makes no sense
all right let's make it a two right no
it was a Sam you're lucky that I'm lucky
that I wrote it uh and then six like a
Bosch yes I knew it you know didn't even
have to cheat
let's get first good man dot jpg all
right creepy corner you can put up the
three items in your quest line that's
what I did like alright so that's why I
have my knife if anyone wanna [ __ ] me
in these corridors can i have a shout on
[ __ ] I'm gonna text some ladies
[ __ ] alright let's keep going if
someone just closed that door oh no
someone takes it means my mom again I'm
gonna be pissed
look to the left look to the right oh no
don't do it
ah oh - creepy that's that's creepy as
hell I don't know if I want to do it Wow
who told me to look today oh you save at
these tape recorder alright so that's
how you do it
lovely lovely lovely lovely oh no I
don't like this
what if that
you have to fight someone I don't want
to fight anyone please don't make me
fight anyone I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm
sorry any meat fall it you said I was
gonna
oh he's following me period everywhere I
mean blood on the floor
yes excited how the [ __ ] did I even get
here
that was a good smash nice time
oh it's on now vacuum enjoy the hell is
that he's smashing teasing me there's
nothing today boss friendship pot behind
odd odd equipment to run up I dropped it
I'm a [ __ ] waiter now stop dropping
it I'm gonna die chop chop chop chop
chop chop chop
oh no well done sir I'd suck at this
game I suck at this game
I didn't even save I thought for sure
I'd say god I think that's it we got
what he came for
right I'm sorry I'm gonna try to learn
what the [ __ ] I'm doing alright anyway
like if you enjoyed and want to see more
cry of fear subscribe to come abroad
today and I'll see you next episode
fun the way share mud village terrible
activate